it's been many years since Lawrence
Brandon donde uniform he volunteered for
military service after the attack on
Pearl Harbor in late nineteen forty one
two years later he and his comrades
landed at normandy the fighting at Omaha
Beach saw some of the single heaviest
losses of the war I can relive every
second of it that I'll getting across
that everything that happened on that
thing even the first time I fired my
weapon and what I found adapt and every
time I far didn't what I've already debt
and the first man us all killed or
anything he would later receive the
Purple Heart a distinction given two
wounded soldiers for the bravery
Lawrence Brian lost most of his hand in
the battler he was carrying explosives
in his bag one of those kids I was with
a shot into it if they paid that block
of TNT yeah Eddie no wood said it on far
and if said it all out and I saw it
spoken before it went all right Lawrence
Brandon lost many of his comrades that
day 70 years later he's now set to
return he wants to visit the cemetery
for fallen American soldiers and find
the graves of those he fought alongside
oh yeah that's all I can tell you about
it ish however favre them his daughter
Jerry is going with him on the journey
which is set to last 10 days she spent
months preparing the trip for her father
I want to see my dad on Omaha page
because that's where my dad was injured
I just want to see him there I think
it's going to be very emotional for all
of us but my dad is just very important
to me and this is an important trip for
him
Jerry visits her father nearly every day
she relishes her conversations with a 94
year old they've talked a lot about the
70th anniversary of d-day and their big
trip well I've been joking on a board
back to the 80 tell Olivia hundred and
four no idea this will be the last I am
absolutely sure and that's something
comes up that i don't know about during
the official ceremonies lawrence brandon
will get to meet President Barack Obama
and will receive another award in honor
of his service